I think it's probably safe to describe
you as fairly libertarian I mean you ran
a group called pimping for Paul Ron Paul
not sure how he reacted to that could
you talk about your personal politics
you do your ideas about legalizing
prostitution extend to other areas of
human activity I try to stay out of
politics you know because you know I'm a
businessman number one and if you stay
away from politics and religion you
don't irritate anybody okay now I kind
of like the way Ron Paul fought okay I'm
a libertarian there's no question about
it's just like John Stossel what is it
about Ron Paul that you like states
rights make your own decisions he
doesn't want the feds dealing with the
states and that's what Nevada is about
states rights county rights make it
letting the community make the decision
of how we should be governed now that is
the last of the live and let live States
I don't care if you smoke weed don't
bother me because I got a safe full of
guns and then I'm in the sex business
you know i I don't I don't care what
your religious beliefs are I don't care
about Ava you want to be a survivalist
and live in the desert you want to raise
Tigers I'm okay with it you know just I
don't want to bother you you don't
bother me you bother me now we got a
problem
you